I have to say you were talking about a
good gig you were paid to watch Kate
Beckinsale and just to be able fight
each other fight each other and you know
and those are mud wrestling what wasn't
mud wrestling really was it but they
were still fighting
so people haven't seen a movie that yes
that's what it is wrestling but the
fight she pointed to the point where
someone wins slashed climaxes yes this
is gonna be huge for people who haven't
seen it yet the movie does have a climax
it's quite good ladies please it's quite
good and I need those women are these
women are absolutely true the most
stunning women on the planet are very
beautiful women and and this sequence is
where they battle each other are quite
fun to watch they're fantastic how many
times are they fun to watch Conan 600
times yeah they were there and they're
both well able to handle themselves I
mean as far as the fighting went you
know I mean Kate Beckett has been
fighting vampires and werewolves for
centuries and thousand for her age 426
exactly well we have a clip here this is
a fight scene I believe this is where
you're obviously you've been given a new
identity a new memory and you're
starting to come out of that and you're
talking to the woman you believe is your
wife absolutely let's take a look at
this clip from the movie Total Recall
oh it's recall has to work what did they
do to you nothing nothing I am i sat in
the chair they they hook me up before
they could do anything the police burst
in they tried to
come here
[Music]
yeah
Wow that is what some love when she
thank you that's done fight move she has
it is I heard some gentleman in the
audience go oh when she attacks you with
it's actually with her nether region yes
well anyway
hurry graph the fight yes I just took it
in the day
[Applause]